جاتني قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ان بلاده مستعده للتدخل في المناطق التي
تقصف منها المدن التركيه الحدوديه واكد ان
هذا التدخل هو حق شرعي لحمايه امنها وامن
مواطنها وفق تعبير
اعتبارا من هذه اللحظه نعلنوا ان لدينا
معيارا واحدا وهدفا واحدا وهو تحقيق امني
مواطنين ودولتنا انه حق شرعي لنا ان نذهب
للنقطه والمنطقه التي يبدا امننا منها
وعلى الدول التي جاءت من مسافه الاف
الكيلومترات لتحقيق امنها باستخدام القوه
المفرطه ان تتفهم حقنا الشرعيه هذا هناك
خط رسمناه في مناطق داخل العراق وسوريا
لتحقيق امن مواطنينها واذا تطلب الامر سحب
هذا الخط وتغيير مكانه اكثر فاكثر فاننا
مستعدون لذلك وهناك اماكن ونتعرض فيها
للهجمات بالصواريخ ولا يحق لاحد ان يما
مانعه في سحب هذا الخط الامني وتغيير
مكانه في المناطق التي تقابل مدننا التي
تتعرض للخاص